Terrell was a fussy eater.
He ate the same thing every day.
He ate cereal and a banana for breakfast.
He ate a peanut butter and grape jelly sandwich for lunch.
He ate pasta with butter and cheese for dinner.
But Terrell's eating habits were about to change.
It happened one Thanksgiving.
Terrell looked at all the food.
He saw that there was no pasta with butter and cheese!
The family started to pass the turkey and mashed potatoes.
They passed the beans and baked apples.
They passed the stuffing and sweet potatoes.
"Grandma Kay.", Terrell said.
"Do you have any pasta with butter and cheese?", he asked.
"No.", she said.
"I do have a gift for you.", she told him.
"You must taste all the food to get it.", she said.
Terrell didn't want to taste the food.
But he did want a gift.
He put some food in his mouth.
Then, he tasted this food and that food.
"Yum!", he shouted.
"It looks like your taste buds are now awake.", said Grandma Kay.
This is my gift to you!
Terrell never forgot that Thanksgiving.
Now his taste buds try everything.